this video is brought to you by surf
shark VPN hey wisecrack michael here
today we're talking about the human
embodiment of the awkward pause the king
of cringe himself Larry David hey
edible underwear between Seinfeld and
Curb Your Enthusiasm our culture has
spent more than 30 years laughing at
Larry David's characters and the
uncomfortable situations they find
themselves in
whether it's Elaine calling a baby ugly
in front of its parents some ugly baby
huh
what did you say
Larry returning to a dinner party that
he ruined in order to retrieve his watch
buh-bye we just can't get enough of this
brand of emotional masochism but here's
the question does the pain and watching
Jerry steal an old woman's rye bread
reveal some greater truth about how we
exist in the world what unspoken
mechanics of human interaction is Larry
teach us what a hug goes on just a
little too long let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
Curb Your Enthusiasm spoilers ahead for
a show with more golf than plot and some
Seinfeld but before we get into it I
want to give a shout into this week's
sponsors surf shark VPN a VPN is such a
great tool because it allows you to
connect to the internet safely and
securely a virtual private network hide
your IP address and protects your data
by sending it via an encrypted tunnel
this means it on your trip to the
library or a coffee shop you're
protected against those sneaky hackers
that hang out on public Wi-Fi trying to
get your passwords VPNs allow you to
connect to other regions in the world
and access content that might be
restricted due to censorship while surf
shark has all the basic functions of a
regular VPN they go the extra mile by
allowing you to turn off all ads while
browsing and they can scan online email
databases to make sure your passwords
are not leached somewhere else on the
internet they have servers in 56
countries and you can connect on all
your favorite devices so protect
yourself online and go to the link in
the description enter promo code
wisecrack and you can get an 83 percent
discount and an extra month for free now
back to the show
Curb Your Enthusiasm is a show about
social interaction or rather when social
interaction fails spectacularly the show
fall is a fictionalized version of Larry
David as he wanders around la annoying
and/or infuriating his friends and
family by ignoring social conventions
that most of us intuitively understand
be sincere about apologizing then snack
on pistachio nuts apologize very little
actually happens on her Larry and his
friends will incessantly bicker over
trivial questions of social propriety
you don't want to be buried next to me
when you're dead I can assume you don't
to be next to me when you're alive but
they rarely make decisions of any real
consequence much like Seinfeld before it
it's about nothing but aside from giving
us cautionary tales about eating Junior
Mints in an operating theater the Larry
David televised universe gives us some
deep truths about how we exist with our
fellow humans that is in breaking the
rules or at least arguing about them
David gets at the truth of why social
norms exist in the first place
to understand how we need to turn to
sociologists Erving Goffman and has
booked the presentation of self in
everyday life Goffman argues that social
interaction is a kind of performance
that we are all putting on for each
other every minute of every day like
actors in a play we spend most of our
time hiding our true selves behind
constructed identities made up of
certain expected costumes behaviors and
lines of dialogue
Goffman contends that not only are we
performers but highly adaptable ones
able to switch roles in seconds and
quickly study up on new ones as needed
in a single day for instance one person
might take on the roles of mother wife
doctor or edit poster and more in the
process said person makes profound rapid
changes in their manners speech patterns
etc without even having to think about
or if you're George Costanza you might
vacillate between unemployed for muggins
screenwriter for 10 marine biologists
corporate sick a pan and man who would
like to be lathered in oil according to
Goffman when we encounter others we
refer back to previous experiences to
quickly decide what sort of scene we
lacked out together
waiter patron salesperson customer host
guests etc and a given interaction the
person with less at stake
will tend to offer the other a bit of
leeway and setting the scene with the
expectation that this same kindness will
be extended back their way in the future
and this way together the participants
contribute to a single overall
definition of the situation a working
consensus in other words a big part of
being human is working with other humans
to select and act out social scripts
appropriate to a given moment
sometimes these patterns of interaction
are so well established that they become
almost unconscious most of us have in
turn
that you don't talk in theaters
double-dip at parties did you just
double dip that [ __ ] it double dip the
chip or break the social contract
implied in picking someone up from the
airport most people also understand what
an appropriate hug duration is on the
other hand sometimes people run into
completely new situations or hit snags
and more conventional ones and have to
work together to define that situation
and react accordingly or you know they
try to do that and fail completely like
when Larry becomes accidentally aroused
after a hug goes on for longer than
expected oh she went over the
appropriate amount of time that I can
have human contact without getting
around I only have five seconds after
that it's out of my control
where he accordingly has to deal with
the fallout from his friends she held
that hook for over five seconds I have
no control after five seconds Larry
finds himself in another script breaking
situation in Kamikaze bingo when his
pharmacist offers a negative opinion of
a drug prescribed to Larry's father you
know there's another drug out on the
market I personally like most of us
might assume incorrectly that the job of
a pharmacist is to just shut up listen
to a doctor and give us our klonopin but
in this case our guy bucks the assumed
protocol for pharmacist customer
interaction and forces Larry to choose
whose performance to trust I'm a doctor
Larry he's a pharmacist yes and I'm a
doctor he's a pharmacist in all these
cases the participants are constantly
making choices for better or for worse
but how to perform and how to respond to
the performance of others in a smooth
social interaction all the various
definitions of the situation will
quickly line up and working consensus
will be achieved just as many of us have
internalized normal behavior we have
also been heavily socialized to tolerate
the behaviors of others even when it's
obviously fake Goffman contends that
this willingness to be flexible with
other people to take their performances
at face value is what allows societies
of all sizes to function everything from
your dinner party to the economy depends
on all of us cutting each other a
certain amount of slack enter Larry
whose entire stick revolves around his
inability or is
outright refusal to reach a working
consensus with anyone while it's
impossible to reduce curb your
enthusiasm to a formula one of the
show's most used gags is simply to put
Larry in a social situation and have him
vehemently disagree with someone else's
definition of it again in Kamikaze bingo
for instance when Larry learns that his
friend Yoshi's father survived his tour
of duty as a world war two kamikaze
pilot he insists that it would come a
Kazi pilot it kind of implies that you
know the kamikaze Boz is a pilot who
crashed died right he refuses to drop
the point and find a working consensus
with his wife and friend even though his
questions make Yoshi visibly
uncomfortable even when it becomes clear
that his prodding eventually led Yoshi
to attempt suicide Larry still refuses
to concede that are still alive you say
that and I say to you they are not
kamikaze pilots Larry is completely
inflexible rejecting anyone elses
definition of the situation he derails
social gatherings by obsessing over
minor annoyances that most adults would
ignore for the sake of a quiet meal with
friends you're really the only person
who has a problem with the water what is
a sensitive about I want you to go when
family friend cliff Cobb tells an
anecdote about his grandfather inventing
the Cobb salad it's my grandfather's
salad Larry thinks he's lying rather
than letting it go like a sane person he
Commission's his secretary to do a
research project on the origins of the
Cobb salad there's no way to do okay I
want you to go in the Internet and get
some information from me on the Cobb
salad later confronting cliff with the
new information the Cobb salad my friend
was invented when Larry is in the room
it is almost impossible to come to a
single definition of the situation that
will allow the group to continue talking
in a productive way the way Larry
constantly sabotages any working
consensus is the key to the show's
famous fringe enos as goffman points out
when these disruptive events occur the
participants find themselves lodged in
an interaction for which the situation
has been wrongly defined and is
no longer define all the participants
may come to feel ill at these Curb Your
Enthusiasm offers viewers the social
equivalent of the physical humor found
in Tom and Jerry The Three Stooges and
jackass that is a chance to laugh at
people in pain while Moe and Larry might
smack Curley in the head or grab his
nose with a pair of scissors our Larry
subjects his wife manager and other
acquaintances to that awful prickly
emotional discomfort we feel when a
social encounter is spiraling out of
control I have a tendency to get a
little chilly when I take my yeah get
the cops coats it probably I'll be a
good idea Larry's refusal to adapt to
any working consensus outside his narrow
worldview causes plenty of chaos and the
occasional screaming meltdown now I'm
saying thank you for helping me I'm
gonna have some cash no but but you
can't change it that's why you say no
matter what this is the what that's why
you asked me and not these other people
because you knew I wouldn't let you
she said no matter what we see this play
out in trick-or-treat the season 2
episode that confronts Larry with two
teenagers pretending to be little kids
on Halloween where most adults would
roll their eyes and toss the girls a few
Hershey bars to make them go away
Larry decides that this is the time to
make a stand yeah I know yeah it doesn't
mean that you're entitled just go around
to people's homes and build them out of
candy when he calls the cops to report
the resultant vandalism to his house the
officer claims that Larry's started the
whole mess by refusing to give the team
any candy there's kind of a social
contract that you went to when you open
that door they say a trick-or-treat I
would advise you give the treat Larry's
wife Cheryl points directly to the big
gap between Larry's definition of the
situation and the working consensus that
gets the rest of us through Halloween
without getting the words bald [ __ ]
spray-painted on our houses in later
seasons
Larry is even called upon to use his
unique capacity for tactlessness to
solve his friends problems when an
attempt to get a mutual friends wife to
stop saying lol backfires Larry's
manager Jeff finally puts a label on his
unwillingness to bend to social norms
you know what you are you're a social
assassin when the social assassin makes
a hit he is killing a working consensus
that is disagreeable to another member
of the group one who was too afraid to
put forward their own alternate
definition of the situation because
Larry would rather be right than be part
of a functioning social group he will
call out any aspect of a performance
that he doesn't like
but how specifically do people create
these performances for each other and
how does Larry disrupt them one way is
by ridiculing and playing around with a
Goffman referred to as the individual's
front or the items that we most
intimately identify with the performer
like insignia of office or rank clothing
speech patterns facial expressions
bodily gestures and the light in Larry's
work characters routinely fixate on one
or more items in another character's
personal front pieces of clothing and
what they supposedly reveal about the
people that wear them our key story
elements in multiple Seinfeld episodes
consider Jerry's horror at the thought
of having his front tarnished by the
pirate shirt or Jerry and Elaine
fixating on how to interpret the meaning
of a cape if you wear
Cape believe is wearing a cape or
Gerry's dismay over the cowboy boots
he's forced to wear these characters
spend an inordinate amount of time
worrying about other people's fronts and
trying to preserve their own you know
the message you're sending out to the
world with these sweatpants you're
telling the world I give up I can't
compete in normal society I'm miserable
so I might as well be comfortable this
carries over into Curb Your Enthusiasm
Larry is often preoccupied with the
minutia of other people's fronts
someone's choice in headgear for
instance will affect whether he decides
to help them pick up a dropped golf ball
same hat no string no question I pick it
up I I see certain items I recoil or
whether he'll take a friend into a
restaurant you don't need to be proud in
there at one point
Larry even picks a fight with Ted Danson
at the man's own birthday party
for having his catering service wear
bowties it looks elegant
Oh feel like you're putting on airs or
something but the show's obsession with
front comes through most clearly in one
of the subplots to trick-or-treat in
which Larry starts wearing golf clothes
on days when he isn't actually playing
golf this confuses his friends who don't
see the point of adopting a front that
communicates golf if one has no
intention of hitting the links Larry
simply likes the way he looks and it
tucked in polo shirt and slacks I like I
like the outfit it looks according to
his definition of the situation wearing
golf clothes does not necessarily imply
the one is going to or coming from a
game Larry
nobody would wear a shirt like that
unless they're gonna go despite his
preoccupation with the front of others
he decides that he can add these items
to his own front without making a
statement about what he's doing for the
afternoon but for the other characters
Larry's front is so tied up with the
practice of golfing that they refused to
believe him when he explains he doesn't
have a round schedule all of that
notwithstanding Larry isn't always on
the outside looking in when it comes to
deciding what's appropriate and what
isn't on rare occasions he is
temporarily able to win others over to
his side and ways the lineup with
Goffman's description of group or team
performances according to Goffman of
group of people defining a situation
together operates a little differently
from an individual trying to do the same
an individual can create a complex
definition of situation for themselves
in contrast a team working together to
define a situation will often have to
boil things down to a thin party line
the lowest common denominator that
everyone involved can agree on groups in
other words tend to define situations in
broad strokes rather than developing
nuanced interpretations to events they
will judge things as simply good or bad
acceptable or unacceptable etc the
members of the team may feel compelled
to defend the party line even if it is
simplistic we see this play out on a
micro level in kamikaze bingo when the
host brother-in-law attempts suicide and
interrupts poker night
those remaini around the card table
aren't sure what to do next
there is no ready definition for their
situation Larry is the first to begin
making one up Wow here we are here
that's true because you know I had to
really finagle to get out tonight I'm
kind of happy to be anywhere and you
know I can't leave the house they're
gone or anything and a pizza is coming
coming
not wanting to miss out on a night of
poker the boys work together to develop
the transparently stupid party line of
of pizza is coming they fall back on it
when the host returns from the hospital
and calls them out on their
inconsiderate behavior but Curb Your
Enthusiasm also explores this dynamic on
a much larger scale one of the show's
recurring themes is Larry's relationship
to Judaism or rather his lack thereof
kur portrays segments of the American
Jewish community as a Goffman style team
a collection of individuals working
overtime to establish what counts as
correct behavior for the group and
condemning anything that doesn't fall
within those boundaries as always Larry
has a tough time achieving working
consensus with the crew which results in
him being labeled as not good enough in
his performance of the faith Larry takes
on this mantle with glee nothing seems
to make him happier than being yelled at
by someone who's trying to shame him for
disagreeing with their definition of the
situation ie what it means to be Jewish
and trick-or-treat Larry gets into a
feud with a man who hears him humming of
vogner tune to his wife Cheryl I want to
know what a Jew is whistling Bob do you
wanna what it was one of the great
anti-semites of the world you know what
you are what am i you're a self-loathing
oh yes but it has nothing to do with
being Jewish
of course the man's claimed that good
Jewish people should not enjoy Wagner
fails to make an impact on Larry who
rejects the consensus he represents
[Music]
and in the season 8 episode Palestinian
chicken larry's love for a new
Palestinian restaurant puts him in
conflict with his Jewish acquaintances
Larry causes friction early on by
violating Marty funkhouser's proud
Jewish man front near the entrance to
Allah bus when Marty later tries to
shame Larry for starting a fling with
the Palestinian restaurant owner Larry
fires backed by attacking his front once
again making fun of him for taking his
religion and culture so seriously the
episode ends with Larry literally caught
between a crowd of Palestinian
protesters on one side of him and a
crowd of Jewish protesters on the other
he's caught between the situation he
wants to eat delicious chicken and the
one he's saddled with a working
consensus that labels him a religious
traitor like many comic figures
Larry gets laughs by flaunting social
norms but few characters are so
single-minded in their devotion to
causing friction I will not be
intimidated even on Halloween while Curb
Your Enthusiasm may make some people
cringe rather than laugh it would be
hard to find a human being who can watch
the show and be completely unaffected by
directly attacking the system that
allows us to interact with our fellow
humans Larry toys with some of our
deepest fears around social failures
shame and flat-out awkwardness depending
on your tastes this is either hilarious
or terrible it's cute right not really
what Larry moments have you survived in
your own life have a favorite episode we
missed let us know in the comments and
as always be sure to subscribe and ring
that Bell thanks to our amazing patrons
for supporting the channel and our
podcast tap that subscribe button and as
always thanks for watching later guys
[Music]